>>Kara: Ok. Hi everybody. Thanks for coming
at the end of the day here, I know its tiring
and you wanna get to drinkin', as do I, but
--
[audience laughs}
but we will, this is gonna be sort of a conversation
so try to close your little laptops and various
devices. And, and we're gonna try and have
a good conversation about where Social is
going. And talk about, we have some great
panelists here, it's a large panel.
I think I was brought in because I did one
recently at Twitter's, what was that called?
SHERP or whatever. How funny. So they so they
I was brought in to sort of, of abuse a panel
of dudes and here I am again which is my favorite
thing. So, again, once again, a panel--
>>Adam: Of dudes.
>>Kara: Dudes, so it's essentially Sausage
Fest Part 2. So,
[panel laughs]
I think I can handle them, though. So, we're
gonna introduce, everyone's gonna introduce
themselves and we have about an hour and I'm
gonna spend the last 15 minutes of questions,
it would be really great because I certainly
don't always ask the best questions. I ask
some good questions, but I think you guys
probably have better questions than I ever
could. So, just think of some questions you
want to ask, and we're talking about a wide
range of things from privacy to mobile to
where it's all going to mistakes that you
all might have made. I know it's not possible
for Google to make mistakes because their
brains are so big, but I think we're gonna
talk about where that's going. Don't laugh.
Ok, anyway, let's introduce ourselves. Starting
with Kara and going.
>>Chris: So, my name is Chris Messina. I am
the Google employee on the panel. I actually
work in Developer Relations on the Social
Web team and I recently joined Google, actually
in January. So, before that I worked for myself
as an Independent Consultant and more recently
I've started working on the Buzz APIs. So,
doing a lot of work to move forward in our
operability in the Social Web and open things
up in general.
>>Neil: Neil Sample, I'm Vice President of
the Social, Open, and Publishing Platforms
at Yahoo. I've been at Yahoo for about six
years and in the valley forever. So I guess
I've probably seen all of it, built a third
of it, and clearly like the Google guys, have
never made any mistakes or stepped in it.
>>Kara: Heh, that's not true. Anyway, go ahead,
thanks.
>>Chris: I'm Chris Cole. I'm a lead architect
with MySpace Developer Platform with OpenSocial
and I've been there a couple years and taken
some licks and I predate the dot-com stuff
so I've seen the that the wave a couple times.
And other than that, I'm looking forward to
the panel.
>>Kara: Great.
>>Adam: Hi, I'm Adam Nash. I'm the Vice President
for Search & Platform Products at LinkedIn,
so I'm responsible for our search engine and
search capabilities as well as our APIs both
on-site and, and off-site and our mobile products.
>>Angus: Hi, I'm Angus from Microsoft and
I work on Windows Live, specifically the partnerships
that we do around social technologies like
Windows Live Messenger, Hotmail, and SkyDrive.
>>Ryan: Hey, I'm Ryan Sarver and I'm the Director
of the Twitter platform. For us, it's obviously
the third-party developers, APIs, content
syndication, and I joined about a year ago
so it's been an interesting ride.
>>Kara: Great. Ok, I'm gonna refer to you
by like: Twitter dude, Microsoft dude, LinkedIn
dude, if you don't mind. Not to be rude or
anything, but that's how I'm gonna remember
best. So, let's talk first, I know, just so
you know one group that's not here is Facebook,
which is obviously, if you've heard of them,
they're a big social network that people seem
to like. So, they aren't gonna be able to
talk about themselves so, let's, you know,
bash them. But one of issues obviously this
week around Facebook is, they should, we should
have a Facebook person here. That said, issues
around privacy have become a big deal this
week. A lot of it focused on Facebook, but
each individually, each of your companies,
Google with Buzz, various, Microsoft has issues,
Twitter's issues with, with privacy and what
happens in this thing. Let's start there because
that's the hot button issue at this moment.
So, Chris, talk-- talk a little bit about
how you look at this debate. Is it overblown?
Is it something that's just too much? Do consumers
care?
>>Chris: Sure.
>>Kara: That kind of stuff.
>>Chris Cole: So, this is one of the, the
things I've been talking to a lot of people
about lately. And I think this is an industry
wide issue which is why each one of us has
had different experiences I'd say with, with
privacy in general. And I think that on the
one hand there are expectations that are changing.
The desire for people to be able to publish
things and have their friends be able to find
them in a way that's meaningful to them, is
very important. On the flip side of that when
people are surprised by information being
shared that they hadn't necessarily anticipated
being found by certain people, then that creates
a tension and erodes trust. So one of the
hardest things that we're having to deal with
now in general and I, I say we as in the industry
is coming up with interaction models that
I think address people's expectations. And
at the same time don't overwhelm them with
too many choices. Because on the one hand
you can frontload all this stuff, like I'm
sure everybody reads every terms of service
before you install software and so if you're
willing to that and you're one of those people
then you probably love eight thousand--
>>Kara: You probably don't have any friends,
then.
>>Chris: That's possible too but if we frontload
the user experience around the privacy stuff,
then people won't use the stuff. If it's not
made so that people have a clear understanding
of where the stuff is gonna go and who's gonna
see it, then they get upset later on. And
I think there's a there's an interesting balance.
One of the things that we're betting on or
at least that I think is necessary in the
industry is for more interoperability. People
can experiment, try new things have different
services that start up with say as being public
like Twitter By Default and let that flourish
and see how that goes and then try other services
that start private By Default like email.
>>Kara: Right. Now, Yahoo has hasn't done
as much they do a lot they've been bringing
Facebook in and some other services into the
service, but in terms of you've tried Yahoo
360, but it wasn't --it was a valiant effort--
but it didn't work in any way whatsoever.
But what--
>>Neil: It's huge in Vietnam, actually.
[laughter]
>>Kara: Oh, great.
>>Neil: But write that down.
[laughter]
>>Kara: It's like Orkut. I had Orkut saying,
"You know, we're big in Brazil." I'm like,
"Nice work."
[laughter]
Anyway, that said, how do you how do you look
at because Yahoo's been very protective of
people. It, it hasn't been gotten stuck in
these privacy problems. What do you think
the big issues are when you look at the other
companies or--
>>Neil: Yeah, I think it's, it's we don't
wanna be throwing stones you know those folks
who live in glass houses. I mean, we've still
got a lot of investment in privacy a large
investment in trust and of course as soon
as I say something some security hole is gonna
open up. I think Yahoo has been more conservative
than, than some of our partners. And that's
one of the reasons why we still have a high
level of, of trust. And I, I have to act on
Chris's point, you have to make it simple,
you have to make it obvious, you can't really
frontload the experience. If you go through
all the nuance of the toss, again, it's not
that there's anybody like that they don't
have friends --they just don't have software--
the crap's too scary to start engaging. So,
you have to make it simple and you have to
make it clean. But the, the interesting thing
I think we've seen the thing that's perhaps
unexpected is that there's, there's almost
no limit to the level of recourse that that
folks seem to be giving right now for Facebook.
That there's enough value in it that, "Ok,
we're gonna, we're gonna screw up and we're
gonna tell everybody what your Christmas presents
are. And then a couple years later we're gonna
accidentally out you through an API and a
couple years later after that we're gonna
move everybody sort of surreptitiously to
public broadcasting of status." And then people
will notice and they'll spin up a group--
>>Kara: And then someday we'll be imprisoning
people with red hair just because we don't
like, I mean it--
>>Neil: The gingers are everywhere. Right!
[laughter]
And I don't know when people are gonna rise
up and say, "No!" That's the thing that's
been really surprising--
>>Kara: That's Google I/O 20/20 just so you--
>>Neil: Yeah, exactly. The end of the gingers.
But, folks have been burned several times
and yet they're still coming back. I have
to believe that there's gotta be a line somewhere.
But we still don't know quite where it is.
That, again we've, we've seen fast and loose
play with people's privacy in industry and,
and nobody's really paying the price yet.
>>Kara: So, MySpace was one of the original
companies that really was sharing. I mean,
pioneered the idea of excessive sharing, some
might say. This has moved to a level well
beyond that. At the time that MySpace started,
it was it was somewhat controversial, somewhat
embarrassing for some people.
>>Chris Cole: Yeah, well MySpace came on at
the tail end of the dot-com bubble. And if
you remember back then everyone was absolutely
beside themselves with fear with this whole
notion of a "cookie". And that you might be
attachable to what you're doing online. And
this debate went on for many years. And then
all of a sudden people are enjoying sharing
things with their friends. But-- but what
bothers me about trend recede is it's gone
so far as there's a difference between posting
something online and having it publicly available
where maybe your friends will copy it and
they might send it to someone you don't know
or don't want it to have it. There's, there's
a stark contrast between that and having something
broadcasted to everyone in the world without
you're necessarily being aware that this is
happening.
>>Kara: Just what Facebook just did.
>>Chris Cole: Yeah.
>>Kara: All of a sudden my children's' pictures
were up on the Web not with my friends kind
of thing.
>>Chris Cole: Yeah, and this is the--
>>Kara: What goes into the mentality of that
because you guys have to, you just put new
privacy policies out?
>>Chris Cole: Yeah, and some of that is more
highlighted in what we've already been doing.
We're constantly tweaking this, but we have
a really deep background in respecting people's
privacy and there's been a number of things
over the years where--
>>Kara: Well, the pedophile, the pedophile
incidence.
>>Chris Cole: Yeah, we've had, we've had a
very sordid history of, of that certainly.
>>Kara: That--
>>Chris Cole: and among other things.
>>Kara: Oh, those pedophiles.
>>Chris Cole: And we've cleaned up a lot of
that over time, so we've been burned our,
in our own right. My fear is that this is
gonna be ignored by the industry to the point
that it'll have to be settled through lawsuits
and tort law and it's the precipice that we're
walking up to right now.
>>Kara: Well, it's a perfect thing for an
Attorney General to make a lot of noise over
for sure.
>>Chris Cole: Yeah, and you're seeing that
in Washington right now.
>>Kara: Oh, I think the FCC is gonna move
very soon if they feel brave. Let's go to
Twitter first. Now, you guys are all about
public broadcasting, so it's as much of a,
I think you've had a Geolocation things like
that where people somewhat are willing to
do that. You guys started out sharing. I mean,
Facebook you started off thinking it was just
your friends and then they suddenly broadcast
all your information outward. Google Buzz,
even Walt Mossberg called me and said he's
my partner, called me and said, "I can't stop
it." You know what I mean? And if someone
who's like the worlds expert on technology
can't stop something from propagating there's
an issue. But, you guys started out that way.
So, how do you, I mean people know they're
sharing with one million of their best friends
kind of thing.
>>Ryan: Yeah, I think part of it's about the
premise that it's founded on. We were somewhat
fortunate through product decisions and, and
just luck in terms of stumbling on a certain
model that that resonate, but people came
to the service having that expectation from
day one. And you opt into that and that expectation
is shared throughout the network. When you
start on a premise of private and small networks
and have to then shift the user base to an
area where you want them to share. I think
that's where a lot of the consternations starts
to happen because most users aren't in tune
enough in the same way we are in the valley
around like, what all that actually means,
what the implications five to ten years down
the road are. So it's very hard to let them
understand the nuances over time. So, we've
been fortunate that we started out with that
initial premise and that seems to be the one
that people are trending towards and we're
able to stay where we are and that just--
>>Kara: You're adding more specific things,
Geolocation, that kind of things, which is
a little more intrusive I would say.
>>Ryan: Intrusive but it's still opt in, right?
And we give people the granularity to choose
what they wanna share. And we, we talked a
long time when we were originally doing Geolocation
cause we wanted it to be like private and
you choose who it goes to and it, it breaks
the model. Like, we want what you share to
be the exact same object that everyone else
sees. So, we try and do it in the same way.
We try and maintain that same product vision
that what you see about your own content and
what your friend sees about your own content.
If it gets syndicated out to Google to someone
you don't know, they will see that exact same
object. And its, so it's about the expectation
of what you're sharing, but I think changes
how people share and people expect--
>>Kara: You think most of the things should
be opt-in? Because this is, opt-in is like
a dirty word for most of these companies.
>>Ryan: [sighs] I think Chris hit on it a
bit, it it's a tough balance between like,
transparency and knobs to turn and all that
kind of stuff. Because users, at some point,
there's a threshold that they just stop looking
at them. So you can give them all the knobs
in the world and I think that's what you're
seeing on Facebook. There's a lot of good
intentions to give people all the control
they want but users, like they look at a--
tossed and glean right over it.
>>Kara: Well, why can't it just be like a
thing that just popped up, "We're about to
put all your pictures out for all your stalkers
to see. Yes or no?"
[Ryan laughs]
I, I'm sure I can write something rather clear
about what's gonna happen.
>>Ryan: Well, I think that's why you see the,
the content shared on Twitter is very different
from the content shared on Facebook, right?
You don't see a lot of photo albums of like,
families and stuff. You see a single shot
of like some event or something you're expressing
or experiencing as opposed to these more personalized
content.
>>Kara: I wonder why it can't be easier. I
mean, why, why--
>>Ryan: I mean it's the simple nuances of
human nature. I mean, there's, you're trying
to take it and make it this digital thing
that has knobs and selections. And there's
different types of relationships and data
flows much more easily, which I think is also
harder when you're dealing with human relationships
it's a little easier to keep it contained.
But where it's digital and it can flow throughout
the network and be syndicated out to millions
of people across the world instantly. It changes
the nature of how you have to think about
it.
>>Kara: But explaining it to people is that
hard? I mean, I think they're, they're aggressively,
purposefully being confusing in a lot of ways.
>>Chris: So, actually, I would, I would respond
to that. Because it's been interesting to
watch how Facebook has tried to explain some
of these things. Specifically, my girlfriend
was using Facebook. And there was some time
many months ago they put up this "terms of
service change" thing where they were inviting
people to go participate. To read whatever
it was they were gonna change. And it was
there for two or three days at the top of
the News Feed, I think this was before the
redesign. And I asked her several days after
when she was like surprised that the terms
had changed. Like, "Didn't you see that thing
sitting at the top of your News Feed, like
blocking your view?" And she's like, "Oh.
I saw that but I just, I didn't engage with
it." So, we've had a similar experience with
Buzz. Where we've also provided certain types
of disclosure about: " Look, you know, you
can enable this if you really want to" but
I think people are oftentimes, they have an
objective in mind when they arrive at something
and they're gonna blow through whatever else
gets in their way.
>>Kara: Perhaps, I mean, unless you give them
a chance. One of the things we did on our,
we, Walt was very particular about making
people aware of cookies and --
>>Chris: Sure.
>>Kara: our headline was "We're watching everything
you do right now. Do you want to do something
about it?" We were very; we were very, getting
their attention. We're sneakily following
you everywhere on the Web. They're always
to alert people.
>>Chris: And I guess if you use it like that,
like, like there's someone looking over your
shoulder right now, don't turn around kind
of thing. I mean, maybe that would work, but
I think when we try to do all these things
across all these different sites in a way
that isn't too alarmist--
>>Kara: Right.
>>Chris: but still informs, I mean, you're
right, unless we're screaming at them.
>>Kara: Why not be alarmist?
>>Chris: I think that--
>>Kara: The weird guy from high school can
find you now. Something like that.
>>Chris: I do want to AB test that. You guys
wanna try that?
[panel laughter]
>>Kara: So, Microsoft, one of you guys, how
do you look at the, cause you have a business
part that is quite privacy oriented and then
you have struggled in a consumer space more.
But how do you look at this idea where people
are doing this aggressive sharing?
>>Angus: I think the key thing is that privacy
is in our DNA. I mean, like you said that
there's the business side where we are quite
private. There's one privacy, like, central
organization inside Microsoft or our Trustworthy
Computing. That's a part of every engineering
process, whether you're working on like, shippable
software, like box product, or whether you're
working on online services. So, I mean, when
it comes to Windows Live, specifically, I
think a lot of what Chris said is, is important.
Like, do not surprise people. And the scary
thing about that is if someone's surprised
then you've already done something wrong.
Like, people need to be able to choose who
can see what of theirs and they need to be
able to get granular or that we need to make
sure that the defaults are set to an appropriate
level. So, it's just about expectation management.
And I mean, with, I think it's about 500 million
people currently have Windows Live ID's, that's
a huge number of people that are, that we
want to make sure we get privacy right for.
>>Kara: Mm-hmm. Do you think it's because
Microsoft's, I mean, of all, I mean, based
on the promiscuous scale, Facebooks way down
here, Microsoft hasn't been as successful
because their lack of promiscuity. I'm trying
to-- you know what I mean?
>>Angus: I mean, I'm not even gonna go there,
actually.
>>Kara: You're not as easy!
[panel laughter]
>>Angus: Yeah.
[pause]
>>Kara: But, why, why, you need to have to
do that?
[laughter]
Do you need to have to get there to be successful;
to be that, you know, give--
>>Angus: I don't think so. I think you can
build a perfectly good business that satis--,
that satisfies tons of consumers and advertisers
by keeping everything legit.
>>Kara: Right. I'll move to a vacuum cleaner
metaphor. They have a giant sucking vacuum
cleaner; yours is less, set on a less level.
I mean, can you be successful when it's not
like that? When it's not sucking every piece
of information ever about you in-, indiscriminately?
>>Angus: I think you can absolutely be successful.
Yeah, definitely.
[laughter]
>>Kara: LinkedIn guy, dude, so you guys I
have to say I think do have the most, the
easiest used tools. To-- and the people on
LinkedIn do want to share. They want to share
information about themselves a lot for jobs,
a lot for job search, and stuff like that.
So the intent is very clear. I find the tools
simple to use; it's very clear about how,
what you're putting up, who's getting what
and it's actually quite protective about a
lot of things.
>>Adam: Well, I think that's, that's actually
part of makes these problems so hard is that--
>>audience1: Microphone.
>>Adam: Sorry? I think that's part of makes
it such a hard problem across the, the social
Web is that context really matters. This isn't
just a technical problem, it isn't just a
cognitive problem understanding what we could
or couldn't do. The fact is no one ever writes
down social contracts, right? Communities
form, then they evolve. We've been very fortunate,
you know. LinkedIn's always taken privacy
very seriously because in business context
there is some information that you really
do guard, right? If you're unhappy with your
employer and you're looking around for a new
job, that's something very private. We take
it very seriously that we always want people
on LinkedIn to feel like they put their best
foot forward. We would never want to embarrass
someone. On the flip side, LinkedIn users
have always been, ever since we launched the
feature, delighted to find out that the first
time that someone Googles them, that their
LinkedIn profile comes up high because that
professional side of you, that professional
persona that we all spend decades kind of
working on through our careers; that's actually
the default one that a lot people are comfortable
with a stranger seeing.
>>Kara: Mm-hmm.
>>Adam: And so, I think yeah, LinkedIn has
done well in this area, but I think that's
partially because we're very focused on our
context and what users want from that context.
>>Kara: But you don't have a whole lot of
information on your thing. I mean, I love
LinkedIn because if I, I'm able to reach all
the Yahoo executives I want to leak to me,
for example, but--
[laughter]
and Facebook works really well, too. Sorry.
Not you. So, not yet.
[laughter]
Do you need to add more stuff to that because
you imagine having, you don't have any pictures,
it's somewhat, not, that's not the right word.
It's somewhat plain vanilla kind of stuff.
>>Adam: Well, yeah, it's focused--
>>Kara: It's like a resume. It's looking at
someone's resume with a little bit more.
>>Adam: Yeah, but, it's only a mix of information
that people share etc., but for the most part,
yeah, your professional profile first and
foremost is that first value proposition that
people get. That, "Hey, when someone looks
for me online, they're gonna see me this way.
This is my role at LinkedIn and previously
I worked at these companies. I went to this
school." We spend a good chunk of our lives
accumulating these experiences and skills
and so I wouldn't say we don't have a lot
of information, I think it actually is not
only a significant amount of information,
I think it's very important to people. It's
just in this context. That's how people want
to present it.
>>Kara: Can you imagine having more information
there? Like, more pictures, videos, things
like that?
>>Adam: To be honest, we're very, we react
what our users want. So I think that as more
and more users want more rich content, we'll
probably provide more rich content. But really
it responds to what do people feel like they
need to represent themselves professionally
online. To date, that hasn't involved a lot
of that rich media.
>>Kara: Mm-hmm.
>>Adam: People don't feel like they need to
represent themselves professionally with photo
albums of their kids or that sort of thing.
>>Kara: Right, right.
>>Adam: I don't think that that's likely.
>>Kara: Right, that's what I think. Let's
move on to, from, before you get into privacy,
what do you think the greatest mistake has
b-, by your own company, by another thing
that has been a, the greatest mistake made
in this area so far? Chris, you start.
>>Chris: You know, I'm, I'm new at Google
so I don't have like, a whole long legacy,
but I think one of the things that was very
interesting to,
to watch unfold was the interesting, the collapsing
of context with Buzz and Gmail. So, we use
Buzz internally at Google, to great effect
I think. And it's been a very, very positive
thing, especially when I first started working
at Google, it was a great way to learn about
my coworkers and learn what was going on.
[clears throat]
One of the things that's very interesting
about dogfooding a lot of these things is
that we learn about the products early. We
try them out. We get great use cases. And
we have a very clear, I think, idea about
how email works and how Buzz works and things
like that and so, watching peoples, I guess,
questions about--
>>Kara: I would say horror, but go ahead.
>>Chris: Questions about the way that they
interpreted Buzz being in their inbox was
something that was fascinating, I guess. Because
it's like, oh, like people expect that if
there's this public context within an inbox
then all of a sudden their inbox is gonna
be made public as well. And, of course, that's
not the case and never was the case, but there
were a lot of people that had that concern.
And I think that there's also a greater context
where there's been conversations happening
about Facebook and about Twitter and about
all these other social services where people
just hadn't anticipated this type of social
environment to be merged in this very different
type of social environment.
>>Kara: Well, it's the way you got in, the
way you're trying to get in. Facebook has
sort of run away with the other part. Right?
>>Chris: You said it. So, I think it's been
interesting to see that unfold and I, I, one
of the things that I'm most excited about
with the APIs is to actually allow people
to build external and different context for
the, the Buzz experience--
>>Kara: Ok.
>>Chris: that can give people a different
type of social expectation or social environment
in which to conduct their daily activity.
>>Kara: Do you think it was a question of
communication, or that Google people just
aren't like other people, regular people?
[laughter]
>>Chris: I think--
>>Kara: I'm saying the last one is true no
matter how you slice it, but what do you think
the problem was?
>>Chris: There's something special about Googlers,
for sure. But I think, I think there's also
a different type of expectation and desire
that a lot of us have at Google to be able
to share one another.
>>Kara: Your test group of dogfood eating
was not a usual group of people.
>>Chris: It was, for someone new to Google,
it was very eye opening.
>>Kara: Mm-hmm, ok.
>>Neil: You know, I think one of the interesting
things about Yahoo is that, you know, collapsing
context is, is not just an exception like
Buzz and, and Gmail kind of combination. It's
more like, you know, taking ev--, a scoop
of everything at Baskin-Robbins and, and putting
it in a blender and then mixing in some motor
oil and then saying, "Mmm, drink this."
[Kara laughs]
You know, yeah, they did. It is, it's a new
product. The McSlurry.
[audience laughs]
But, you know, the interesting thing is, you
know, we had these; we had listings properties,
right? Where, where folks where they're at
Hotjobs. You know, you were there for sort
of this commercial intent job seeking. We
had Yahoo Personals where you were there looking
for somebody but you sure as hell didn't want
anyone to know you were looking for somebody.
And then we have email. And then have photos
in the form of Flickr. And then we have media
experiences where sometimes it's programmed
and other times it's sharing, it's groups,
it's answers, it's message boards, it's all
these sorts of things. And so the biggest
challenge, and I think, the thing that we
never really have solved and, and has again,
led to some of our conservativism is it's
seemingly impossible to cross all of those
streams. Is that if you start with a sort
of vertical notion, you know, whether it's,
it's sort of LinkedIn, right? It's, its business
oriented, it's very specific, the purpose
is there. Or even Twitter where it's a channel.
You just say, "Look, I've got a channel and
I'll let the user program it in any way they
want." It's, it's fairly straightforward to
go ahead and manage that. And so I think one
of the reasons we've been slower and, and
have missed other opportunities, if you will,
that other folks have captured, like 360,
is that it, there's no compatible way to mix
all of the Yahoo pieces together. And so I
think that remains a challenge.
>>Kara: It wasn't confusing to the user.
>>Neil: Right. It wasn't confusing and therefore,
we didn't do it, right?
>>Kara: Cause it does freak them out. I remember
when Facebook went on The Huffington Post
and think, and I didn't turn the thing off
and I wasn't in stealth mode and then I realized,
everyone realizes, all I read is Brittney
Spears' stories and Lindsey Lohan's stories,
so.
>>Neil: We knew.
[laughter]
>>Kara: I know you knew, but, arrested! She's
getting, she is, by the way.
[laughter]
When she enters the state again, she'll be
in jail, deservedly. So, but I mean, I think
it was the lack of; it doesn't mix. I was
just reading The Huffington Post and all of
a sudden I was sharing my strange predilections
on celebrities and--
>>Neil: Right. And you know, we, we had an
internal discussion recently about Facebook-like
buttons. You know, the thing is when you share
something on Yahoo, i--, it's not as bad as
here you're stalker buddy is gonna see it,
but we, you know, we are sort of in your face.
It's a proactive notification and there's
a message that says, "This is who it's gonna
go to." If we were to take, you know, like
buttons and put them all over our media pages
or sports or you wanted to like a team or
like a sports figure, there's no notification.
It's a different model and so, so maybe it's
ok for those users for a while until you know,
again, the next, the next--
>>Kara: They realize.
>>Neil: the next boo-boo or mistake happens,
but you know, we found that even the open
parts of the Web are a bit more promiscuous
than our users are willing to take.
>>Kara: What about at MySpace or anywhere
else?
>>Chris Cole: So, I would say--
[audience member coughs]
with regards to privacy, there's probably
two mistakes I've seen over the years. The
first one would be to initially over allow
photos and things that should be private to
get out there. Like, early on you alluded
to a lot of the problems with the under 18
versus over 18 and then how do you manage
privacy between these groups. And because
of those early mistakes, the company overcorrected
and has been very conservative in how we allow
people to share. And in some ways, I think
we put in undue friction, like when we initially
launched the Developer Platform one was allowed
to invite one friend at a time to share some
sort of game or app with them. And the reaction
was developers found workarounds to that that
were incredibly annoying to the user and we've
missed on opportunities like Twitters broadcast
channel that perhaps we would've been really
well positioned to have taken advantage of
had we continually re-examined this notion
of privacy. So, it's, it's a really hard line
to walk where you're private enough that you're
not damaging your user base but public enough
that you're allowing people to have social
experiences.
>>Adam: Yeah, you know when I think of different
challenges we've had here, actually we similar
to Yahoo may have had a little bit of the
reverse where. I'm very excited that we were
able to launch the open developer platform
with LinkedIn around Thanksgiving; that was
only about six months ago. Until then, you
know, people who wanted to build business
applications or other applications to integrate
with LinkedIn, they either had to queue up
and wait for personal attention, which, of
course, being a small company was hard to
provide. Or they'd have to find another way
through the shadows, through the grey areas.
And you know, everyone knows, we're all very
clever. We can come up with clever ways to
solve these problems. You know, one of the
benefits of having an open platform now means
that first of all, our users have come to
expect that they've invested a lot of time
in their LinkedIn identities; they don't really
understand why all applications don't have
access to that information. They expect that
if they give permission they should be able
to access that anywhere on the Web. But more
importantly, it brings that activity in to
the light. Right now, people are using a real,
robust authentication system. People are now
putting all that activity through in a way
that our standards for privacy can be enforced
across all those interactions. So, while I'm
very proud that we have that open platform
today and we're actively working on improving
it and expanding it, I think it was a mistake
to not have it until six months ago. I mean,
there were a lot of things we were figuring
out, but I'm glad that we have it now.
>>Angus: A few people have talked about missed
opportunities and I think that what I would
like to see more of is actually spending time
together working on these complex problems.
So, like, I was just at an Internet Identity
workshop earlier this week down at the Computer
History Museum and there were like, key people
from each of the large and small online services
all in one place. That should be where like,
I personally wanna drag my engineers down
to. I wanna spend more time, I wanna get more
people from these companies to spend more
time and I think that's the, that's both a
challenge and it's also a competitive edge--
>>Kara: I like that coming from Microsoft.
You mean you regret being a bully for all
those years.
[laughter]
You should. Just sayin'. It's so funny, Microsoft
is so friendly now, it's really hard, I covered
the Microsoft-, I covered the Microsoft trial;
you weren't always so friendly, just FYI.
But, it's nice. It's Angus. It's the accent,
anyone, it's Scottish, right? Yeah, anyone
who talks Scottish to me, I'm like, "Oh, you're
so nice."
>>Angus: I'm Australian. Come on!
[laughter]
>>Kara: Ok, that's good, whatever. OH! Oh,
no!
>>Angus: Are you Canadian?
>>Kara: Right, I like Australians, too.
[laughter]
No, I'm not Canadian. Although, I was married
in Canada, not that anyone cares, but anyway.
[laughter]
>>Ryan: You know, I, I think we're still going
through a learning, we're s-, I think such
a different model, we're still trying to figure
out where the edges of it are and what mistakes
we're making. I think some of ours aren't
gonna show up for a little while longer, but
it's still sort of--
>>Kara: You fail well. I go right to fail
well.
>>Ryan: Well, that's too obvious sometimes--
>>Kara: Not really, but a pretty big mistake.
>>Ryan: And there's all sorts of company learning's,
but if we're talking about the social aspect
of it, I think some of that is still yet to
be determined and allowing applications to
like, for you to give trusting applications
they can essentially go do anything for your
account. We've kind of fought very strongly
to keep away these like, very discreet permissions
around this app can do this and this app can
do that because, I think, we don't wanna get
into that kind of checkbox fever of like--
>>Kara: The only thing is it becomes third
party applications then you do one, say that.
Because those, that's not Twitter, necessarily,
I mean, that's an issue on Facebook when you
give permission to third parties if you don't
know who they are.
>>Ryan: Well, well, and so we, I go about
that the other way. I think trying to give
the granular permissions to apps up-front
aren't the right way to go; it's more about
policing them and using trust models within
social graphs, trying to understand which
apps you trust as opposed to saying, "This
app can do these things--
>>Kara: But the company should be the one
determining who's trustworthy.
>>Ryan: No, I think it's the users and the
set of users that determine which apps are
trustworthy. We actually even backed this
idea of expectations in our privacy policy,
we've said, like "Don't surprise users with
anything you do and if you surprise them for
any reason, like Tweet on their behalf and
you didn't make it clear enough and you thought
you made it clear enough, but if they're still
surprised, we have the ability to revoke your
application."
>>Kara: Let's talk about mobile; where we're
going with mobile. This sort of geo-, I think
it was combined with Geolocation and mobile,
where that's going. And we'll finish up talking
about, and we'll get to questions about where
things, sort of where it's all going and,
and even, you know, there's so many social
networks and so many choices people have to
join now. You have to be on Foursquare, then
you're on Facebook, and then you're on MySpace.
It, it's very confusing for users I think.
We'll talk a little bit about that. Let's
very quickly talk about mobile and how you
look at it. I think it's critically important;
a lot of this mapping and location and it
creates a more useful experience to a lot
of these social scenes. So, let me start.
How do you look at the mobile space right
now? And where do you think the key, the key
players are in it?
>>Ryan: I mean, mobile is original part mobile
is part of our DNA. I mean, that's where Twitter
and the short code and the short character
count and all that stuff; it's pure mobile.
We happen to have a Web service that allowed
you to surface the content. But it was about
sharing things on the go, in real time, with
people pushing messages back and forth. So,
everything we do have a very deep mobile consideration.
Location is something kind of near and dear
to my heart, too, because I spent a bunch
of years in that. I'm really excited to see
confluence of like, real time, location, and
mobile all coming together because all sorts
of new use cases and experiences are gonna
come together and flourish because of those
things coming together at one time.
>>Kara: What's the most interesting use you've
seen of that so far?
>>Ryan: Some of the ones I, I personally love
are the ones like the Food Carts and Emergency
Accounts or seeing this like, real time data
that's pertinent to you because it's about
the proximity in your relationship to it.
There an Emergency NSF account and there was
a gas leak like two blocks away from my apartment
the other day, and I get device updates for
that and granted, it was just outside of the
zone, but it's something, it's something you
wanna know. I wouldn't have tapped into the
Web to notice that, so you want that to your
device. It would be better if the device knew
exactly where I was and where the originating
Tweet was and could make that connection easier.
>>Kara: Get away from the gas leak.
>>Ryan: Get away from the gas leak, yeah.
If you get this run--
>>Kara: Run now.
>>Ryan: Run now. We're not gonna tell you
which direction, but--
[laughter]
So, I think that's the kind of stuff that
I love seeing those kind of use cases come
out of it. And I think we're gonna see more
and more of those as all those technologies
come together. Location for so long was so
impossible to get to and now it's like, free
on every major device and that is just like
game-changing in so many ways. I'm excited
to see how it starts to play out.
>>Kara: It's becoming more specific, which
is nice; really locating you nearby. One of,
one of the things Walt tested once is this
thing you put on children and you locate them,
except the kid was always like, three blocks
away from where it was. It was close, and
the company said, "Well, it's close." And
we're all like, "Do you have children? Because
if the pedophile's like three blocks away
and." And now it's becoming like, location,
we're happy it's getting specific. Anyway,
so, Angus from Australia, --
>>Angus: I'm glad you remembered my name.
[laughter]
>>Kara: I do.
>>Angus: It's no longer Microsoft guy.
>>Kara: Microsoft dude from Australia. Anyway,
Aussies, kangaroos, I got it. Koalas. So,
shrimp on the barbie.
[laughter]
What, how do you look at location? You guys
are doing amazing things in mapping. I mean,
in that area, Microsoft's been incredibly
aggressive and really giving Google a run
for its money in terms of like, putting out
features and doing interesting stuff in mapping.
So, I think you and Google are pretty, the
leaders in this area, sort of, pioneering
innovations.
>>Angus: In terms of location, I think it's,
it like, location is about exactly where you're
at and that means it could be physical home.
Like, someone could stalk you if you accidentally
connected to
a network that leaks it out to the public
Web. That's like, real danger. So, it needs
to be watched super carefully--
>>Kara: Well, if you leave your house. I'm
leaving my house now with my 16 iPads and
that kind of thing, please, help yourself.
>>Angus: Yeah. I think the thing that bums
me about location and mobile is that there's
so many different places where my friends
spend time. So, I've got some friends on Foursquare,
all the hip ones, then got some other unhip
ones on Gowalla, and some, some other services.
>>Kara: Leave poor Gowalla alone.
>>Angus: And, and it's hard for me to stay
across exactly what they're doing. And if
I wanna be able to consume that information,
I wanna be able to bring together the places
where I feel I have people I care about and
I quickly wanna get that into an easy to consume
interface.
>>Kara: So, you'd like to have that confederated
in some fashion.
>>Angus: Yeah, and some of the stuff we've
been working on with Windows Live Messenger,
in terms of bringing in things you care about
from your best friends.
>>Kara: Your company could be one that confederated
Facebook, Google's another. I mean, in terms
of there being so many of them. There's Booyah,
there's all kinds of ones you guys just did
the Booyah deal.
>>Angus: Yeah. But, we've been doing some
of this with the social networks. So, we announced
a partnership with Facebook, MySpace, and
LinkedIn--
>>Kara: And you did a Foursquare one, too,
I think.
>>Angus: There was a brief, little demo with
Foursquare. But, once again, location is an
area that you need to be careful and you pointed
out that we were down one end of the scale
and I think that's probably a space that,
but, I'm not sure where we're moving in terms
of location.
>>Kara: Right. Is there other location issues
with LinkedIn?
>>Adam: Not issues--
>>Kara: Mass rush for this job down the street?
[laughter]
>>Adam: Yeah, well, if the economy hadn't
gone a certain way, it might have been a bigger
thing. We'll probably be active in consumer
location. Events like this are part of what
we hear from professionals, right? People
wanna know, not just which of their connections
are here at the conference, but who are the
people they should meet at this conference?
>>Kara: That sounds really annoying, I have
to tell you. But go ahead.
>>Adam: Yeah, well, that cuts both ways. But,
we haven't, this is what we're hearing from
users, right? You know, we haven't built a
feature like this yet, but we hear from professionals
is that, there's some people who are here
from Google I/O for fun and entertainment,
but most people are here because it directly
relates to what they do for a living. Their
job, their profession, building their skills.
A lot of people spend their time thinking
about who they can meet here, when they can
meet and that sort of thing. And we don't
have all those pieces, but we do have that
professional context, we do have reputation,
their connections, etc. We do think we have
a role to play to provide some of those features
to make that a more productive experience.
I mean, an ideal sense, it would help you
just as much to make sure that you're spending
your time with the people you should be rather
than ending up spending your time with just
whomever you randomly run into, if that makes
sense.
>>Kara: Good point, that's a good point.
>>Chris Cole: For us, is we're looking at
the trends. It, it's very clear that all of
the growth is on mobile and something like
30 to 50 percent of our users are dealing
with mobile devices and I think it's a majority
of status updates are coming from mobile devices.
So, so it's very clear that mobility in this
always on always with you connection is really
kind of, where the social--
>>Kara: You guys are doing a lot of events
around that, about event-going--
>>Chris Cole: Yeah. We're doing a lot of Geolocation.
Not so much at the point geolocation, at this
point more of the geolocation of "you're in
this city" and then "these are the concerts
coming towards you that you might be interested
in". But, but it's also interesting because
I was talk-, I forget who I was talking to,
but they were looking at the usage patterns
and some mobile devices are used first thing
in the morning and then very late at night
right before you go to bed and the type of
content you're gonna tailor to that is gonna
be very different than say, looking through
someone's photo album of their trip to the
Caribbean and their marriage.
>>Kara: Tell me something cool you've seen
it used for.
>>Chris Cole: Well, something I haven't seen
yet, but may be out there would be location-based
activity stream updates so that you could
then prioritize what's around you, stuff that's
really happening. Because right now the stream
comes through and it's your friends, which
there's some geolocation just naturally from
that, but something that, we consume the Twitter
stream, have partnerships with a lot of people,
so we have this massive amount of data and
if you could create some sort of graph notes
structure then had location and made it more
relevant by location, that would be very interesting.
>>Kara: Something through in a Firehose now
and it's somewhat relevant--
>>Chris Cole: I mean, the Firehose is amazing,
but it is just a Firehose. You can't drink
it.
>>Kara: Ultimately irrelevant, excuse me,
relevant. I recently used Foursquare to bother
Fred Wilson because he was in a restaurant
around the corner. I was just like, "Hi! Nice
to see you." Freaked him out, even though
he's an investor in Foursquare. He's like,
"How did you find me?" And I'm like, "You're
an idiot."
[laughter]
So, what about, what do you see that's interesting
in mobile? Something, some interesting use
of it, or where do you imagine that?
>>Neil: Yeah, I think, you know for Yahoo
mobile it's, it's just obvious. One of the
differences for the way we do it in--
>>Kara: You have a mobile announcement Monday.
Wanna tell us what it is?
>>Neil: My manager would kill me.
>>Kara: Yeah, well, I'll be writing about
it tonight.
>>Neil: I heard when she was walking over
that you'd already gotten there.
[laughter]
>>Kara: Yeah.
>>Neil: Suck it.
[laughter]
So, you know one of the interesting things
is traditionally mobile has been more of a
read experience for Yahoo.
>>Kara: Right, you guys had Yahoo Go, which
was a very, another valiant--
>>Neil: Yeah, eh, eeh.
>>Kara: Valiant.
>>Neil: Marco, love him, you know.
>>Kara: Yeah.
>>Neil: I know he was a friend of yours, but
for us it was a read-mostly experience and
so we hadn't, because we're not often writing
location except to our own APIs because you're
searching for a restaurant or a review, or
you're there on search and you're drawing
a picture around the neighborhood that you
want results from, you know, that kind of
thing, it's not as much of a challenge in
the social space because we tend not to be
exposing. Or if you look at the new iPad app,
you know, it's there about consuming media,
whether it's media content, reviews, and that
sort of thing. So, for us, it's an obvious
vehicle to push our content, to push our experiences,
but we haven't had the same privacy concerns
because we're not generally publishing from
the devices that often. So, we use the mobile
cues; use the geosignal and that sort of thing.
But it's, it's, it's far less intrusive because
we don't have a, a privacy issue.
>>Kara: What would you like to see Yahoo do?
>>Neil: You know, in the ideal world it would
be nice to just forklift everything. That
you could take Yahoo, run it through a magic
filter, and then all of a sudden it's appropriate
for a two inch UI. I think, you know, there's
some promise in HTML5 and some other technologies
that will get us closer to that as we move
to, to standards and, and portable development
that'll work well in both places, but you
know, that's more of a technology thing than
a social thing. I mean, that's the ideal is
sort of the write once, run anywhere and I
don't have to care if it's on a, on an IP
TV or a set-top box, or a com-, or a full-fledged,
you know PC or hack a two inch device, right?
>>Kara: It's a nice dream.
>>Neil: Yeah. It is. It's the Holy Grail.
[laughter]
>>Kara: The impossible dream.
>>Neil: Yeah.
>>Chris: Actually, on that point, I would
say that that's a nightmare. Being a designer
by training, because I feel like when we separate
out mobile from other types of computing experiences,
we tend to put it in this like, little bastardized
tube that like, says, you know, "Have these
experiences over here and we just wanna take
all these desktop experiences and just throw
them into this small two inch real estate,
and things are just gonna magically work out."
And I actually think that mobile demands and
deserves a certain type of thinking that's
much more contextual, that takes much less
for granted, and greatly simplifies the computing
experience. So, like, awhile ago, I started
thinking about how there's this emerging trend
in computing that I call "pop computing",
which is about simplifying these experiences
that we take for granted that we'll have with
a mouse and a keyboard and getting them down
to like, a single mouse-touch, sorry, a single
finger-touch, and that changes everything.
It's a fundamental paradigm shift in, so--
>>Kara: Well, isn't it computers, well, don't
you feel, I feel that computers are going,
I mean, I have a five year old who literally
touch-, literally every screen he touches,
like he bangs on it like it's like, a village--
>>Chris: Essentially, yeah, it's, it's, he
can't touch it right? So, we have these weird,
stupid screens that sit there and you like,
like, paw at them and they don't do anything
and it's like, "Well, it's broken."
>>Kara: Mm-hmm.
>>Chris: So, in a couple years, I can imagine
people are gonna have these expectations,
or they're gonna look back at us sitting in
these weird cubicles with these computers
that we interact with in this way that seems
very foreign to them because they're used
to having tactile experiences. So, if you
couple that tactile experience in mobile devices
with location, which is all about relevancy
and what's around you, and what's very immediate
to you, I think people's expectations are
changing. And so, we have to think about the
context that someone's gonna find themselves
in from a social perspective, from a geographic
perspective, and from an immersive sort of
like, "Are they driving while they're tapping
on your device? And if so, they really should
not be having like 40 lines of text like in
front of them." So, it demands a whole new
discipline and that I think we have to consider
and not just port, you know, what we've had
to that.
>>Kara: Very good point. Country-minute Nicole
Kidman? I'm just curious, Microsoft had a
wonderful movie idea a couple years ago about
this idea of on-the-go, also Russell Crowe,
they had a really good movie of this idea
of on-the-go computing kind of thing. Did
you see it? It was called The Future of the
Future, or something like that. It was one
of those great Microsoft movies of things
they're never gonna make but it looked terrific.
It was like, you touch things, you move things,
you, you sweep things--
>>Angus: Minority Report?
>>Kara: Yeah, it was like Minority Report,
it was really cool.
>>Angus: Yeah, I've seen a couple of things
there, but I haven't seen that one. But I've
seen Office 2019: Workplace of the Future.
Actually, sorry, Chris, I was sitting next
to someone with a laptop, a Windows PC, and
they were tweaking the screen yesterday. So,
it happens, right?
>>Chris: It's coming.
>>Angus: That happens, sorry. And one last
thing, I just wanted to update. What cuts
me really deep about mobile and social is
that I have a set of friends. I, I use a certain
device cause it was given to me for work.
You guys use other devices because, for whatever
reason. I hate that the device or the app
defines who I can interact with in a certain
way.
>>Kara: Good point.
>>Angus: That really bums me out.
>>Kara: That's perfect. Let's get to that:
devices. Now, let us try not to insult Apple
27 times today, it's gotten a little much
today.
>>Ryan: I love them.
>>Kara: You do? Ok, good. Your boss not so
much. But, but, let's talk about what the
important devices. That is, there have, we're
getting into this ridiculous, juvenile, typical
of Silicon Valley war between all these platforms,
with Apple and Google being the most obvious,
but Facebook and, and Google and all these
people in these different and all the different
devices fighting with each other and then
Palm's over here dying slowly until HP buys
them. How do look at, it's a good save, how
do you look at this, this idea, what you're
talking about cause it's very, it's problematic
because there are all these little fascist
organizations here and here and here and you
belong to the, you know, it's like the tea
parties versus the crazy liberals versus the
crazy, well, the nutters, you know in this
country are politics now become the nutters
running each side of the spectrum, running
everything. And the people in the middle are
just vomiting, you know, quietly in their
mouths.
[laughter]
So, how do you look at, how does this solve
itself when these devices don't, you know,
my, I mean, I have a Nexus One, my, but there
is a certain use case of these things that
you become this, this Apple person, or this
Google person.
>>Angus: I think the key thing is that, first
off, Chris mentioned that the experience on
mobile is key. And generally you'll see the
first party, like the service owner, they
order a killer client a la Twitter. You guys
build a killer client for certain devices.
And then it comes to, "Well, what other devices
do people want to build for?" And making sure
that, like, as a service owner, you should
be saying, "I'm not gonna build for that device,
but I'm gonna find the best person that builds
on that device and I'm gonna give them all
the love and the attention so they can satisfy
the people that have friends that use my services
on other devices."
>>Kara: But you do have to choose now. A lot
of these devices, you know, even on our site,
we're not gonna spend a lot of money, but
we went to the iPhone first and then we were
gonna go to the Blackberry, and then we decided
to go to the Android, but here's the iPad.
You know, I guess we'll go to the iPad first;
it just becomes for the developers worse and
again these wars that are going on.
>>Adam: I think, sorry, I think that this
is actually pretty important. Mobile is a
big deal for us because professionals have
two things. They tend to be higher income
so they can afford these latest devices and
services and they're never at their desks,
so they really depend on the mobile devices.
But, I don't see the problem, the reverse
there it is a problem, but it becomes an obligation
from a design standpoint. People pick their
devices just for reasons and I don't think
it's wrong to ignore them, right? You know,
we, we have, at least in the Android application,
we had a lower, you know, working on one--
>>Kara: The first one was an iPhone, right?
As are most peoples.
>>Adam: The first one was an iPhone. But you
have to ask that question, "Why do people
love the iPhone?" Right? That's part of why
they chose that device and that fits into
what do they need to go, like, we design our
applications. We don't say, "Well, what parts
of the website can we bring onto this mobile
device?" Its, "We have a mobile professional.
What do they need to get done one the go,
quickly, easily. And how can we bring it to
them in a way that they're truly gonna enjoy?"
The, the, a mobile device, like a PC, is a
very personal device. It knows everyone you're
connected to, you pick it and there's this,
and the tactile thing makes it even more personal,
so it may be a problem in terms of you can't
possibly build your app for a hundred different
devices, but for me, at least from the design
perspective, it feels very important to make
sure that if you're gonna build an application
for Android, it's gotta be a great Android
application.
>>Kara: I'm talking about the ability of being
in the silos--
>>Adam: Yeah.
>>Kara: which is the opposite of open--
>>Chris Cole: I think in, in this crowd in
particular, we talk about ok, iPhone versus
Android and whatnot. And we're ignoring this
entire class of devices out there that we
have a much younger skew on our user base.
So, these aren't people that can walk out
and plop down two hundred dollars for a device.
You know, you live in Silicon Valley, you
live in Seattle--
>>Kara: You're talking about the [inaudible]
phones.
>>Chris Cole: You walk around and everyone's
got their iPhones in their hand and more and
more you see a lot of Androids. And the reality
is that you're ignoring a significant portion
of the population if you don't look at the
older feature phones and the WAP browsers
and what they can do. And this is, I would
say, I wish I had committed all these statistics
to memory, but it was close to the 50 percent
mark, over or under or older WAP devices that
are connecting to our site. And, you know,
we talk about what we're doing, but particularly
in a social situation, you're trying to get
information and interaction out as wide as
possible so even if you're going and hitting
all the smart phones, you're still completely
ignoring a huge portion of the market.
>>Kara: Yeah, but at the same time though,
although, although the trend is towards these
smart phones--
>>Chris Cole: Clearly that's where it's going,
but it's still a couple years out.
>>Kara: I mean, everyone's gonna have one.
I mean young and old people, as soon as they,
you know, we're showing ten tablets of [inaudible]
in a week, you know? And there's, and they're
gonna be cheap and eventually go down and,
you know, with the Kin, by the way, the Kin
was on Gossip Girl the other night. That was
fascinating. That idiot, Chase Crawford, was
trying to, anyway. But it was cool to see.
But, but, people will have smart phones; so
therefore, it does become this kind of thing.
We're gonna go to questions now, but what's
the most important device right now in the
mobile space? You first.
>>Chris: Wow. That's a terrible question.
>>Kara: No, it's not. It's a great one.
>>Chris: Well, actually I'm really excited
about the, the Chrome TV today. The Google
TV in the sense that it's not a mobile device
but in the sense that it takes the Android
platform, pushes it into a new environment
and provides this way of actually doing this
cross platform development that, to me, working
on identity for the last couple of years--
>>Kara: Tough area. People have tried. This
has been a battlefield--
>>Chris: raises, and it raises a lot of questions
about how you actually like, sit like, take
an Android device, interact with your TV,
bring that into other places and contacts
and so on. It's forcing the boundaries of
these things to actually congeal in ways that
are unnatural, so.
>>Kara: It's a tough buts, it's taken many
prisoners in this particular area over the
years.
>>Neil: Yes, you know, I'll, I'll cop out
on this one. I think the answer is whatever
is in the consumer's pocket.
>>Kara: Oh, good God.
>>Neil: Is you have to, you have to deliver
your app and, and so I'll give my own story--
>>Kara: Short. We gotta get to questions.
>>Neil: In this pocket, it's the iPhone, and
in this pocket, it's the Blackberry, right?
But with the iPhone, with the car I bought
recently, one of the features it had to have
was an iPhone jack. And why does it need an
iPhone? Well, cause I read more on my Kindle
now on the iPhone. I actually, Rhapsody plays
on the Phonos, the TiVo, and oh yeah, it plays
on the iPhone. And so the interesting thing
I think, is that when you get convergence,
you know, for me the, the phone isn't an end,
it's a means to get to the stuff that's interesting
and I think the approach we have to take is,
you know, sometimes we call them Hero Devices
in the industry, is we focus on those devices
because they're gonna enable so much for users.
And, and you know, you can again try to leverage
whatever you have into a WAP device. But,
at the same time, I think it's important to
say, "Look, I can carry the entire ecosystem
of this user, I can do a better job, I can
get them their music, I can get them their
content, I can get them the books, whether
its DRM or not, yadda, yadda, yadda." So,
I think whatever consumers have, if you can
bring your experience there, that's how you
win. It's about the experience existing on
the device and if you can't carry it to the
device, then, you know, it's not that interesting.
>>Kara: Next. Very briefly so I can get to
questions.
>>Chris Cole: I, I think, putting on my developer
hat, it has to be the iPad because it brings
in the whole tablet form factor. It's, you
know, ten months ago it was, "Oh my Lord,
we have a, a three and a half orange screen
that we have to program for." And now it's
this, it's created this new level of uncertainty,
you know, it's hard enough that the Droid
has a different aspect ratio from the G2 or
the Ion phone and now it's like, "Oh, well,
that's the least of our concerns." So, how
is that answer gonna come? Now you're gonna
be developing a Web application, an iPhone
application, an Android application, an iPad
application, a Google TV application, and
no, now we're getting screens in cars so you're
developing a, one for the Volt in the backseat.
So, it's just, it's this uncertainty in how
developers are going to address this a figure
out either increasing their efforts to bring
in clients and all kinds of new experiences.
Is it gonna be market segmentation, it's just
a, it just point, it puts a finger on disruptive
these new devices are gonna be.
>>Kara: Very confusing. Very briefly do you
wanna say something sorry.
>>Adam: Yeah?
>>Kara: Quick.
>>Adam: Huh?
>>Kara: Quick, quick.
>>Adam: iPad, different reason. I think that
the iPad is a signal of everything effectively
becoming a mobile device, not just the traditional
things we think of as phones. I think of the
use cases of someone with an iPad, someone
with an iPhone, someone with an Android device,
how they are wrapped together I think bring
the power of mobile computing to all devices.
I didn't think I'd have to think that hard
about it. When the iPad was announced when
I got one, I'd been playing with it for a
few weeks. It's a big deal. So--
>>Kara: Some of the others coming out are
very exciting.
>>Adam: Absolutely.
>>Angus: I'm pretty jazzed about the Windows
Phone 7.
>>Kara: Of course you are.
[laughter]
>>Angus: I'm particularly jazzed--
>>Kara: Keep, keep trying.
>>Angus: because I have one of a handful in
my backpack, so I'm pretty happy about it.
>>Kara: Yeah.
>>Angus: And what I really actually like about
it is what I've been working on with Windows
Live, is bringing together other, like, other
places where I spend time connecting to Windows
Live. When I turned on my Windows Phone 7
and connected it to my Live account, including
my Facebook account, I saw the activities
that I see in Messenger and I see in HotMail,
which were just announced. I saw those, but
on the phone, in the right context. When I
flipped the photos, I saw it in a really nice
way. And I was just like, "Wow, I can stay
across what all my friends are doing on this
device just as well."
>>Kara: It's called the iPhone, but great.
[laughter]
I'm teasing.
>>Angus: You don't get to see it.
>>Kara: Crocodile Dundee, I do too.
[laughter]
I've already seen it.
>>Ryan: I'm kind of surprised no one here
has actually mentioned SMS. We're talking
about smart phones and addressable markets,
and SMS is billions of people, not tens or
hundreds of millions; billions of people.
And it might not be as high fidelity, but
some--
>>Kara: Ok, great.
>>Ryan: of the most important messages are.
>>Kara: Ok, questions? Please be questions
because I'm forcing these guys. Anybody?
>>audience2: Going back to the privacy question,
you mentioned that we shouldn't surprise users.
The problem is what happens when you don't
even know the impact? For example, the fact
that once you publish something, you may be
sure that you want it to go out on Twitter
to everyone; you're fine with that. But then
this thing gets archived, its searchable--
>>Kara: Right.
>>male audience member #2: long time later
someone find some innocent looking comment
and they take it totally out of context and
that's bound to surprise people later on.
So how do you deal with that? How do you make
sure that people understand that, you know,
a shard snippet today may make sense based
on the context people have about you, but
then--
>>Kara: Ok, one person answer that? Who wants
to answer that?
[pause]
Google guy.
>>Chris: So, I think, on the, on the one hand,
there's gonna be a generational shift and
part of it is, is learning how these tools
work and unfortunately its gonna take a lot
of the media hyping that's going on now to
get people to tune in to this conversation
to become more aware of it. So, there's no
perfect answer today, but I do think people
are going to learn one way or another.
>>Kara: Yeah, I think it's never, it's never
coming back. I think it's out there and gone
forever. There's a New York Post story on
my pregnancy that I wish I could get rid of.
[laughter]
>>female audience member #1: Hi. I have a
question for all of you actually because one
of the things that I find is missing in all
the social networks today is actually a way
in which I can manage my contact group itself.
So, what I mean is, like, if I look at Twitter
and I'm getting my followers, I follow a bunch
of people and on here I meet someone, add
them to my list, same goes for Gmail, for
Yahoo, you know. But, when I try to set privacy
preferences, you either make me pick every
person in my contact and decide how I want
to work with them, or I have to come up with
groups, which, of course, change over time.
So, my question is why not kind of have someone
that actually look at managing your contact
groups in a way where, as a very simple example,
if it could remember the context in which
I added or changed a contact, and brings it
up to me when I have to set privacy preferences,
maybe I can dynamically create groups?
>>Kara: Great question. Yahoo guy should answer
that.
>>Neil: Yeah, you know for us it comes again
back to that diversity. We do have a lot of
different places where you can manage these
things because, you know, the folks you follow
on Flickr aren't necessarily the folks in
your address book, aren't necessarily the
people you email frequently. But, I think
there's a tension there not only with that,
but with the way people use things. You know,
you could, for example, be a Facebook user
that's a family broadcaster. You have 20 people;
maybe managing the whole list all at once
is totally appropriate. On the other hand,
you probably have more than 20 friends and,
and they're probably different levels of,
you know, of closeness and so, it is times,
at times challenging to build a product that
satisfies both types. To satisfy a commercial
entity on Twitter, like a brand or a product
that's being followed has different needs
and capabilities, you know, for management
than a, than an individual, right? So, it
is a challenge, I don't think there's any
single solution. If there were I think somebody
in the industry would've stumbled on it already.
>>Kara: Quick questions, everybody, cause
I wanna get everyone's questions.
>>male audience member #3: Quick question
for, this is for Twitter. You guys announced
your Library of Congress Preservation Deal
last month and I think for the first question,
I was asked about retention of that data,
and I think that is going to be a hot button
issue, particularly for younger people; younger
generation they see a lot of stuff that, I
mean, watch trendy topics and imagine that
being in, being archived in perpetuity. So
I was wondering if I could maybe get you to
address maybe for on the user case, that you
could allow the people to opt out of that,
so it's not the default. Because the only
way to not be in the Library of Congress is
to kill it in the 23rd week, which is what
hackers like me. I hacked together a, you
know, an app just to do that so that, that
won't happen, you know what I mean? Because
I, I think the intention is the real time
communication, it's not necessarily, it gets
stale, and after that it has very little value
for the author. It has value for everybody
else, but not the author. So, I was wondering
if you have given any thought to allowing
users to opt out of that Firehose feed to,
to The Library of Congress.
>>Kara: He doesn't want all his little updates
shown, right--
>> male audience member #3: Or, or kids, for
that matter.
>>Kara: Or kids, sure.
>>Ryan: I can't speak for the whole company
because I don't know the exact details of
it. In general, obviously we have delete features
and you can't selectively opt out of specific
syndication deals, but I know that there are
ways to delete that data out. We, you know,
all of our syndication deals when we send
a delete through the system; they have to
respect those deletes also. So, I don't know
if there's a single button you can go click
to opt out of that one specifically, but it's
something to look into.
>> male audience member #3: No, there's not.
It should be, but the deal was there's a six
month embargo or a period in which you can,
you can delete it, right?
>>Kara: But then after that--
>> male audience member #3: But people won't,
so again,
>>Kara: Yeah.
>> male audience member #3: programs have
come up with ways around it, but anyway. Reten--,
retention, I think is gonna be a huge issue.
>>Kara: I'm gonna go on to the next question,
that's an excellent point. Two hundred years
from now, someone's gonna be researching in
the Library of Congress reading all those
Twitter feeds and is gonna wanna know, "What
the hell was wrong with our society?"
[laughter]
>> male audience member #4: I don't know where
the social Web is going, but I know that it's
getting a lot more complicated very quickly
and you guys keep adding features and changing
things and, and people are getting more and
more dazed and confused. So, --
>>Kara: Yeah. That's cause they all have ADHD
at 40 FYI, just so you know.
>> male audience member #4: So, so, are you
guys gonna keep doing that? Or, do you think
there will be a backlash and, and you guys
will be forced to make things more transparent
and simpler and easier to use?
>>Chris Cole: Well, it's just the nature of
software that the first thing you look at
is adding features. Reducing complexity is
a much harder problem than adding a new feature.
Over time I would see, that, and you do see
some shift in the public spec groups about
just adding richer metadata around it, even
this Open Graph Protocol is very interesting
because it simplifies the problem of when
someone shares content on a site; it makes
it much easier to scrape the content. So,
as far as adding--
>>Kara: No, no. It's gonna be more complex.
I'm gonna answer--
>>Chris Cole: I don't think they're--
>>Kara: Microsoft guy, they love features
at Microsoft.
>>Angus: Yeah, I don't know how you can like,
why would you measure yourself on the number
of features you build and ship. Like, that's,
like, it's about the killer experience that
you're giving consumers and so, like, I'm
not about pushing code every night but creating
something that's coherent across, like, the,
the phone or the PC or the inbox or the IM,
like, I, I mean, feature count is dumb. Like,
listen to--
>>Kara: And yet you all keep coming out with
more features then, then, you can imagine.
It is true, it's completely confusing, I agree
with you. You're absolutely right. Quick,
very quickly, I would like to get to everybody.
>> male audience member #5: So, Google TV
came out today and it brings up the new social
context of the, the living room. And I know,
is, is there some way to make an Android for
more than one person in the family to be logged
in? Are we no longer going to be fighting
over the remote, over the login? And is, and
is anybody else dealing with the collective
identity piece that goes into social behavior?
>>Chris: I'll try to address that quickly
so we can get all the other questions. But,
what I saw today was that there could be multiple
Android devices that are tethered to the same
TV. Now, from an identity perspective, that
confuses the hell out of me. But I think it's
awesome. So, there's this whole weird context
and confluence of identities being used simultaneously
on a computing device that we've not seen
before, which raises a whole host of questions
which don't clear up answers. So, I think
its gonna be very interesting to see what
happens when there are two Android devices
tethered to a machine and then it has to figure
out what kind of recommendations to provide
to one or two or both of those people. So,
I don't have a great answer, I think--
>>Kara: I think it's the same old story; fighting
over the remote.
>>Chris: Actually, it's a good social experience.
>>Kara: Now, I wanna watch The Notebook, I
wanna watch Terminator.
>>Chris: So, it's complicated.
>>Kara: Yeah. But that's true, it's what they're
gonna--I've seen some people carry, you know,
it's the one person in the room right now
that gets precedence over others.
>>Chris: But, but so the Android, the, the
TV shown today allows for both to control.
>>Kara: Yeah, utterly confusing.
>>Chris: Utterly.
>>Kara: Ok.
>>Chris: Awesome.
>>Kara: Real quick.
>> male audience member #6: So, this, this
is, I, I'd like an answer from each of you,
but it's gonna be really quick--
>>Kara: No, one.
>>audience7: What, what open initiative do
you see as being the most important for developers
to watch over the next six months? For example--
>>Kara: Ok, one more answer for everyone.
>>Chris: Activity streams.
>>Neil: Ditto.
>>Chris Cole: There's too many to give an
answer.
>>Adam: Mobile.
>>Angus: I think the Open Web Foundation legitimized
everything, like, let's do it properly.
>>Ryan: OAuth identity, probably.
>>Kara: Yeah, Right here?
>>female audience member #2: One of the things
I saw in Buzz early on was all sorts of IP
aggregated things from Twitter, from other
places and I loved that about it and I'm wondering
if you see more of that sort of aggregator
so people can come in from various silos using
whatever interface they want and get their
information together?
>>Angus: Aggregation is not the answer, either.
Its, otherwise, you end up with more, like,
confusing stuff together. You gotta bring
it together, curate it, and then surface into
the right area at the right time. Like, aggregation
is not, it's a, it's just a way to get people
shouting.
>>Chris: Well, at the same time, I think one
of the things I'm most interested in, in seeing
how activity streams can actually be used
as a cross industry way of moving this information
around on the first silo, then on the second
silo allowing for relevancy engines to actually
custom tailor information so that it's more
relevant, more interesting, based on the things
you care about. I know, for example, I had
my Twitter feed pulled in to Buzz in the beginning
and a lot of people hated it because it was
completely non-contextual and it seemed like
I was, like I had Tourettes or something,
so I had to turn it off. However, over time,
there might be more interesting social fidelity
that can be derived from more and more richer
metadata, so I think that the, you know, the
final answer is not there yet, but, but these
streams allow for more experimentation to
occur.
>>Kara: Ok, sorry guys, she just told me she
had one more question. This woman here is
waiting, sorry. You guys can come up afterwards
and ask them.
>>female audience member #3: What are your
thoughts on projects like Diaspora? Do they
have a shot in the future against social networks
like Facebook?
>>Kara: There's no Facebook person here.
>>Chris: So, Diaspora is a distributed, open,
privacy-centric, something, keyword, buzzword,
aware social network, that raised a hundred
and seventy bazillion dollars on Kickstarter--
>>audience9: And other projects like that,
too.
>>Chris: And other projects like that, too.
I don't mean to like, you know, disparage
it at all; I think it's actually very important.
I think it's really important for the ecosystem
and for a broader community to have conversations
about projects like that. However, I think
that it's incredibly important for projects
like that to also promote the adoption of
technologies that already exist, that have
been developed over the last several years,
to solve those problems specifically because
if we just end up with more fragmentation
or more geeks running the stuff on their own
hardware, we're not actually solving the problem
for the broader audience. So, I really, you
know, wanna see them succeed and I wanna see
them contribute to the ecosystem--
>>Kara: Do you-- I kind of look at them as
a little Tea Party.
>>Chris: The Tea Party Open Source Social
Web, it's great.
>>Angus: I think there's gonna be more of
these random, little, vertical social networks
or random horizontal social networks in different
geographies. I mean, Kara, you were trashing
Orkut for being big in Brazil.
>>Kara: I didn't trash Orkut, I'm just saying
they're big in Brazil.
>>Angus: You said it's--
>>Kara: It's not as big a deal as being big
in the United States, Europe, and the rest
of the world, but that's just me.
>>Angus: Even on the surface, it looks like
there's aggregation, I'm sure everyone may
have a account with a social network. There's
gonna be more and more of these distributed
networks, more fragmentation for more niche
things and we just need to bring it together.
>>Kara: You're right. I like little Orkut.
He's adorable, he' a sweetheart.
>>Angus: I like Gowalla well, I didn't mean
to trash it--
>>Kara: That's fine. Say Gowalla again cause
it sounds better in Australian. It does. So,
anyway, you're last thing? Did you want to?
>>Ryan: No.
>>Kara: No, ok, great guys. Come by, come
and ask them any questions you want. They'll
hang around here for a minute and then thank
you very much and please give a round of applause,
they did a great job.